the first play I ever saw I was in
junior high school was a high school
production of noël coward's blithe
spirit which seemed to me absolutely
magical I had never seen people
performing on a stage before it was so
different from television or movies of
course I didn't know at the age of 12 or
however old I was that I was going to
end up being the drama critic of a
newspaper but the the experience of
seeing people on a stage sharing the air
that you breathe being part of your
world instead of people on a flat screen
was very powerful for me and I know that
it pushed me in the direction of wanting
to be a performer of some kind I loved
music from earliest childhood from as
long as I can remember and the house was
full of Records my father had lots of
old records seventy-eights big bands
jazz that's how I first heard Armstrong
really and all the other kinds of music
that I ended up writing about and
ultimately playing I became a
professional musician and played all
kinds of music I played bluegrass I play
classical music and for many years I
played jazz but it was the records there
wasn't a lot of live music that you
could hear where I came from which was a
small town and southeast Missouri there
was an occasional concert that came
through but basically my experience of
music and largely of the Arts came
through television more than anything
else back in the 60s when I was a boy
you could turn on Ed Sullivan on Sunday
night and see ballet companies and jazz
and classical musicians along with
ventriloquist's and people who span spun
plates on the ends of poles and I think
the fact that television brought you all
of these experiences on a kind of plane
of equality had a real effect on how I
ultimately came to view the arts because
for me all the arts are one they're all
music and drama and film and
and painting they're all trying their
different ways of trying to do the same
thing and I've always experienced them
on this plane of equality and really
from the time I started writing about
the arts I've tried to write I wanted to
write about all the arts I wanted to
have the opportunity to do that and
finally I got it now I write about
whatever interests me
I was writing throughout the time that I
was performing I started I edited my
high school newspaper you know I did the
things that a young writer does and they
were parallel tracks for me criticism
was simply an opportunity that came up
when i was in college to do some
reviewing and i found that i liked it i
found that i liked the idea of being
able to communicate your own enthusiasm
you're on excitement to try to get
people to come see something that you
saw and maybe see in it what you saw and
somewhere along the way I came to the
conclusion that i was a bit of writer
than I was a musician that I was just
better at it and I decided that that was
what I wanted to do
neither all the arts are our personal
and important to me it obviously
somewhere deep within me there is the
fact that I have been a musician and
it's as though that's my first language
but I've been writing about other things
for so long that the thing that excites
me most is the thing I'm going to see
tonight